russia says it has captured the
strategic ukrainian city of liman in the
donbass region the russian onslaught is
causing heavy ukrainian losses and a
large number of troops risked being
surrounded in the city of sierra donetsk
it's also raising fears that cities in
the donbass could face the same horrors
that took place in mariupol where
russian artillery blasted the city with
no apparent attempt to avoid civilian
casualties
russia first invaded donbass eight years
ago capturing part of the industrial
region now it says it aims to seize the
rest dw correspondent matthias bilinga
has visited one town living under the
shadow of war
for years occasional shelling has
occurred here
but now the shells hit daily
welcome to new york
that is what this town on the front line
in eastern ukraine is officially called
german settlers picked the name in the
19th century
stalin renamed it novgorodskaya
the name was officially changed back
last year
boris bocherov a local poet
was hoping the name of new york would
bring a new spirit to the former
industrial town
there's no production anymore we thought
the name would attract investors who
would help us
this building has been restored with
foreign aid
we've been holding forums and cultural
events here
now bomb craters line the road in front
of the cultural club
several shells have hit the neighborhood
my windows burst and the roof was lifted
i was sitting in the basement when it
happened
instead of reading his poetry botcharov
now looks after the remaining
inhabitants and organizes aid
i'm in the basement every day we've been
sitting in basements for eight years
yes
many houses in town are damaged or
destroyed
three-quarters of the 8 000 inhabitants
have left
those who remain live in constant fear
elena vashtuk is picking up the pieces
a rocket came down in her yard two days
ago
we're trying to replace the doors we
found some old ones because there are no
more doors
not here and not there
i don't even know what the use of
restoring everything is we fix it now
and tomorrow another shell hits
boris has evacuated his wife to western
ukraine where his daughter lives
you see what's happening here
nevertheless he's determined to stay as
long as help is needed
as the saying goes hope is the last one
to die i'm on ukraine's side
i trust the news and i was born in this
town
i hope there will be no incoming shell
sounds almost like we need to dive
just months ago they were dreaming of
creating a cultural hub in new york
now it's all about surviving
well dw correspondent rebecca ritters is
in keeve and earlier she told us ukraine
is struggling to hold back the russian
assault in donbass
well the situation in the donbass is
going very very badly for the ukrainians
at this stage pablo excuse me uh the
they've been admitting for a couple of
days now that they have lost the upper
hand there that russia really has the
upper hand and is dominating the battle
in luhansk and donetsk and as you heard
from that report that certainly seems to
be the case 95 percent of luhansk is now
under russian control
and they are
going forward as well the city of
several donetsk where most of the
fighting is now centered in that region
uh they the russian troops are now
encircling that city there is some mixed
reports as to whether or not the
russians have gained control of that
city russia saying that they have
ukraine saying that they haven't yet but
they have said for a couple of days now
that they may have to pull ukrainian
troops out of that area in able to to
shore up defenses further back they just
don't have the the heavy weaponry they
need to be able to hold back the
russians and push them back they're
they're calling uh on the international
community pleading with the
international community to send these
big weapons particularly multiple rocket
launchers particularly rather multiple
rocket launchers that can fire up to 300
kilometers in the distance they need
this kind of weaponry if they're going
to be able to stop
russia's advance but whether it comes in
time really remains to be seen pablo
well in his daily address ukrainian
president volodysilenski talked about
the human cost of war
how bad is the situation for the
civilians stuck in the areas under
bombardment
as we know civilians
always pay the highest cost in these
situations in these wars the people
living in that area as you heard from
some of them you know the situation is
really dire for civilians i mean
similarly to what we saw in places like
mariupol that were being completely
bombarded for weeks months
people have to live completely almost
underground they they don't have access
to fresh water they run out of food
you know they're living in darkness most
of the time they're being completely
pounded by russian and and also
ukrainian uh bombs in defense of the
regions as well so you know these
situations uh is just dire for the
civilians on the ground and it doesn't
look like it's getting better any time
soon
rebecca ritter is in keeve thank you
meanwhile russian president vladimir
putin has again spoken to german
chancellor olaf schultz and french
president emmanuel macron by telephone
he reportedly told them he's ready to
talk about lifting a blockade in the
black sea
that has hit ukrainian farmers hard and
is threatening a global food crisis
a bumper crop
usually that is good news for a farmer
but with exports out of ukraine's black
seaports blocked
these grain silos in dinipro are still
full from the last harvest
you can see that the field is in
excellent condition the harvest will be
good but where should we keep it we
don't know
road transport is a last resort
but it is too slow to empty the
granaries
the next harvest is due mid-july
if ports remain closed
this farmer says he faces bankruptcy
closer to the shifting front line
farming may be too dangerous
these fields near harkeef have been
reclaimed but they are still littered
with mines and shells
some farmers continue to seed the soil
with the limited equipment left
there are a lot of holes
the whole farmland is full of holes left
by shelling
we don't have strikes right now
but there are shells and rockets on the
ground
so we drive past them and still
seed what else can we do
russia has said it would be willing to
allow grain exports
if the west end sanctions
as food prices continue to rise sharply
the ongoing crisis is expected to push
millions more around the world into
hunger